there was a time when the internet was a
lot like Disneyland it was a fun place
that you would go to you couldn't stay
there all the time but you could go
there and if you wanted to visit this
magical land you would literally have to
plug your phone into your computer and
then you had to endure the predecessor
to dubstep theater and then you're on
1994 I started working for MTV and MTV
had a deal with America Online everybody
connected to the Internet through AOL it
was all you had my first screen name was
craptastic at AOL pay money 17 akane to
$2.99 neon penguin 5,000 back then no
computers weren't compact they were in
the living room you only had one
you never had any privacy with that
computer I mean whatever you did
everybody saw pretty much have to
readjust my sleep schedule just so I can
find the right time to get on the
computer I would wait till everyone was
sleeping I would sit in our finished
basement in Michigan and I would hop on
chat ASL 16f California and I would
literally stalk other people's
conversations and when they would start
arguing with each other I couldn't like
throw in little comments like oh no I
think so-and-so is right and it I was a
troll I was I was a troll
oh my god I've never thought of that
before until just now my mom she was
always working so like no there was no
dad around to kind of show me the birds
and the bees and the internet was kind
of my first exposure to that it was more
intimate and all of your interactions
were more one-on-one I miss those days
those were days compared to what we have
now
it just seems primitive and strange and
weird everything was made out of words
and letters even the nudity it meant a
lot more to get on the internet back in
the day you didn't have as much to pick
through and the good stuff was just
there it was a luxury it was something
that you know with very special whatever
happens happens what I've used crazy new
things I'm running into it was a
different time and you're lucky to have
missed all of it